[важко видихає]
Це озеро в Скалистому
в колишньому кар'єрі.
Воно у мене в фейсбуці стоїть на обкладинці,
тому що це така візитівка цього міста.
Тому що моє село Скалисте зараз
більш відоме цим озером.
Від цього озера до мого дома приблизно
метрів п'ятсот.
Там п'ять хвилин ходьби.
В цьому кар’єрі ми з пацанами в дитинстві грали,
а потім його наповнили цією водою
і поставили дуже красивий, великий басейн.
Коли я вже багато їздив по Україні, по світу,
я розумів, що краще, ніж Крим, нічого не може бути.
Ну там пройшло все моє життя,
народився і жив тільки там.
Хоча багато подорожував,
але все дитинство, вся молодість пройшла там.
Води трохи забагато, ніж було до цього.
Там, де хлопці граються, там далі був проїзд.
Десь метри на два був менший рівень води.
[зітхає]
Це ліс неподалік від Скалистого.
А, це Бакла. Так.
Зрозуміло.
Це неподалік від Скалистого
якесь стародавнє селище печерне.
Ми тут теж ходили з хлопцями і з родиною гуляти.
Ну трохи далеко, там десь годину
треба йти лісом, але там дуже красиво.
У Криму подорожувати дуже зручно,
тому що ці відстані дуже невеликі.
І завжди змінюються ці ландшафти,
такий є і лісовий, і гористий, і морський,
і степовий [ландшафти], і пустелі.
Там все є.
І це дуже класно подорожувати, дуже прикольно.
Я усюди був дуже багато разів.
Ось там неподалік, де йде дим,
це так зване друге Скалисте,
тому що Скалисте складається з двох селищ.
Тут теж знімали декілька фільмів в радянські часи.
Таке місце для відпочинку
у вихідні дні.
Тому що пішки йти трохи більше, ніж годину,
на автівці їхати трохи менше,
але це таке місце для відпочинку вихідного дня.
Красиве дуже, прикольне.
Так.
[сміється до себе]